[Musica]
e venuto lo schifo è però sempre sognato
di farlo
[Musica]
salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliare un canale il
canale di i crew i due ragazze che fanno
video veramente molto molto divertenti
hanno iniziato da poco ma si vede che si
divertono in quello che fanno poi volevo
dirvi si hanno tolto la mia ultima
recensione quella della croce dalle
sette pietre per contenuti pornografici
quella scena fetish e sadomaso non è
piaciuta nessuno a quanto pare detto
questo iniziamo il film di oggi e io
posso consigliarti l'ho io il film o
daniele ciao sì perché no si chiama
prime al park anno 2005 regia di george
miller a ho visto solo il trailer ma
quello sembra già fatto a posta per te
ok da e se lo trovò ci dà un'occhiata
barriere cosa ma che cazzo mi hai
consigliato sa che non va cosa che non
va
cosa che non va
ecco cos'ha che non va
numero 5
i dialoghi i dialoghi perché anche i
dialoghi possono essere squallidi rossi
mio caro su firma dei dialoghi che più
li ascolti e più di venti stupido un
esempio è il dialogo che hai il
belloccio del film che guarda caso c'è
sempre nei fini squallidi con una gnocca
random del film che non c'entra
assolutamente con i personaggi
principali
e una strofa
gli orecchini ti ringrazio sei carino
come ti chiami giorni io sono sharon o
come il mondo ma my sharona
canti niente male e grazie ma talmente
imbecille talmente inutile che mi vien
da piangere oppure ancora peggio di
questo ancora beach di questo è un
dialogo verso la fine del film in cui
l'azione raggiunge il suo apice e non
dovrebbero esserci però di stupidi
perché se non la tensione cala quel poco
poco poco di tensione che c'è cala che
tutto il gruppo in seguito da queste
tigri dai denti a sciabola geneticamente
modificate hanno paura sono dei cunicoli
bui i loro amici sono morti c'è sangue
ovunque e di cosa parlano questi
imbecilli
se ti faccio una domanda
tutti arabi dipende
[Musica]
perché tutta questa cosa dei dark prima
vuoi essere anticonformista e poi ti
vesti come gli altri dark
daniele che odio
numero 4 tigri dai denti a sciabola la
trama è un gruppo di scienziati crea
chimicamente delle tigri dai denti a
sciabola primitive per aprirci uno zoo
sono fatte così male no in realtà no sai
non è quello il problema non sono fatte
così male oh mio dio sono fatte male ma
non così tanto male da essere squallide
il problema è un altro
ma l'iter e dai denti a sciabola nella
preistoria avevano il visore termico no
perché a quanto pare è così che vedono
[Musica]
andrebbero bene per il nuovo spider 7 è
un altro problema è quando queste tigri
attaccano le persone il 90 per cento
degli attacchi non lo fa vedere regista
perché non sono capaci a farlo al
computer in realtà qualche attacco c'è
ma giusto un paio non sono tanto male
tipo questo
come la pace ne sono altre che non ho
proprio capito
cammina maledizioni non vorrei finire in
pasto al velino
è questo qua righe ma intanto mi devo
subire i osti filmarci
numero 3
reazioni umane
quante volte io ho parlato delle
reazioni umane nei film squallidi
macello di volte ma ne azzeccassero una
non ne azzeccano una direzione umana io
non sono uno psicologo ma più o meno
riesco a capire quando deve urlare devi
scappare o devi sentire dolore tipo in
questa scena qui la guardia infine
attaccata da una dire che gli sta anche
un braccio e lui
neanche un gridolino di dolore isterico
da checa niente
che non urla di dolore perché un film
squallido perché vende di prendere il
fucile nonostante sia senza braccio
perché un film squallido perché con
questo genere di film è meglio se non ti
fai domande se non finisci più guarda
altra psicologia umana mandata [__] e
quella di quel personaggio che entra
nella foresta dove ci sono le tigri e
vede per terra ghezzi di piede e pezzi
di braccio staccate ovunque e lui cosa
fa o vita si spaventa scappa perché c'è
salvo ovunque sa che ci sono delle tigri
fa più altri 2 riesce a capire che
cavolo sta succedendo lasciano
indovinare no neanche per sogno
[Musica]
karin
b
numero due prologo patetico
perchè devono smin chiare il film nei
primi dieci minuti come come fai a
smentire un film legge come faccio io a
capire che il film è una porcata
allucinante
nei primi dieci minuti di film e provo è
una parte importante nei film perché dà
il via a tutta la trama
ovviamente le tigri in questo specie di
do scappano e ovvio ma secondo voi
come il guardiano si addormenta sul
pulsante e apre il cancello no arrivano
gli animalisti li fanno fuggire
no
e magari le tigri si fanno aiutare da un
gatto delle pulizie saldano sopra la
spina torino se ne vanno via
magari
guarda il guardiano sta leggendo
una rivista porno dove io traditore
strappa una pagina di questa rivista per
un motivo a me sconosciuto perché la
strappa e basta senza riso la
motivazione la pagina con il vento ora
oltre la recinzione lui apre la porta di
questa maledetta recinzione entra nello
zoo la tigre lo sbrana e sono libere
cioè entra nello zucchero una donna nuda
sì cioè no perché la donna non è neanche
nuda e vestita più o meno vestita cielo
ma li recuperano tenta di recupero una
pagina porno per una donna semivestita
gli accidenti
come si può definire una persona in
questi casi idiota
no io stavo pensando più a testa di ca
io do b no no no io mi rifiuto
categoricamente di commentare questa
scena lo fai tu va beh non credo che sia
mese difficile fame.la vedere
[Musica]
chi ha creato io
fermate
lo capisce adesso lo capisce contro cosa
devo combattere ogni volta che guardo un
film squallido avanti ne provo a
commentare questa scena
dilettante neri vediamole insieme
come vedete c'è la tigre che sbatte
contro la porta ed è fatta più o meno
decentemente perché diavolo
la statua forma di the hive è fatta così
di merda o poi la scena in cui cade il
dente ne vogliamo parlare in nome se non
ne parliamo ma guarda te basta
dio perché non ce la faccio più